departed treasurer of the SNP has
revealed he did not know about the
parties recently seized 100 000 pound
motorhome Colin Beatty who was arrested
and released without charge by detective
last week revealed to reporters He was
unaware of the luxury vehicle which was
removed from the house of Nicholas
sturgeon's mother and all as part of the
finance police probe Mr Beatty quit the
role as the snp's money man following
his detention as part of the
investigation examining six hundred
thousand pounds raised for the cause of
a second Scottish referendum when asked
directly if he knew about the motorhome
purchase he replied no I don't know
about it
what I would like to say is obviously
you guys are hoping that maybe I might
give you some additional information
some point of view that might help
develop the story that's out there
unfortunately it's an ongoing police
investigation so there's very little I
can see but what state do you leave the
SNP in the snp's finances well the smps
and the black
so you're not going bust you're going
concerned we're going concerned
definitely why are you finding it so
hard to find an order till then if you
are going concerned apparently I'd say a
market situation
Andrew
Columbia you quit the economy committee
as well
uh no plans at the moment why is that
when you've been under police
investigation
I think that uh we'll just see how that
develops are you a fit and proper person
to be in these committees I would say so
that's my opinion should should you be
suspended by the SNP
uh no comment on that Colin is this the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
no I was in Beirut actually when I was
under artillery fire that was worse okay
did you know about my time did you know
about the motorhome purchase and did you
sign it off no I didn't know about that
okay